okay continuity I'll give you the
definition first so maybe you want to
jot this down continuity of course our
informal definition I think is probably
best you can draw the thing and never
lift up your pen okay but that won't do
for proving that something is continuous
so here is the definition to be able to
draw something from left to right and
never pick up your pen you have to be
able to go to a certain value right from
the left hand side and you should be
able to find that that's the same as
going to that same value from the right
hand side because otherwise like you'd
have to have picked up your pen I should
be able to go from both directions and
get the same thing yep that's right
so please note by the way that minus
side it attaches to that a not - I
haven't drawn it very well I'll draw a
bit lower there we go so it means go
toward that number a from the left go
toward that number a from the right
there's one more thing that you need
excuse me which is for the actual spot
at a to exist and be the same okay
so I'll give you an example that that
breaks that very simply if I ask you to
graph this before you do any kind of
manipulation you can see the X can't be
0 right because then you get 0/0 and the
universe explodes ok
so I can say that X can't equal 0 but
once I recognize that I can simplify so
what does this thing look like it's the
straight line y equals x but it's got a
hole punch dinner right literally a hole
puncher so this is not continuous
because even though when you come from
the left so say the origin you go
towards zero when you come from the
right you go toward zero but right at
that actual spot it breaks down right so
this is equal to this but it doesn't
equal to this because it doesn't even
exist okay you can also show for
instance for a function like say y
equals 1 on X right how can I prove that
this is not continuous
and not just not just look at a drawing
and say because the drawing says sorry I
would say the limit as X approaches 0 of
1 on X is going to be positive infinity
all right but only when you come from a
particular direction because if you come
from a negative direction you have got a
positive number divided by a negative
divided by really small negatives but
they're still negative and what we were
talking about with regions before you
won't get a positive infinity we get
negative infinity it only happens when
you're coming from the right hand side
because then you've got a positive
divided by a positive alternately if you
divide sorry if you approach from the
other side you don't go to the same
thing you go to a negative value so
therefore I can say since one limit is
not equal to the other limit therefore
whatever X is not continuous now I want
to make one more point on this and then
really that's I probably said too much
obviously it's not it's not as I
wouldn't worry about it too much
do you notice I can't just pick random
values of of a right for example if I
did this whole thing all over again and
said hey let's think about what happens
when you're going towards to the value
two if you come from the right hand side
what do you approach and the answer is
you approach 1/2 if you come from the
left hand side guess what
you're still going towards 1/2 so these
two are equal it's fine 1 over X is not
discontinuous everywhere it's only
discontinuous at particular places right
so if you're supposed to prove that
something is discontinuous you have to
know where to look and they'll give you
an easy function where it's fairly
straightforward ok but you know if I
changed it to this testing that zero is
no point right because I just shifted it
five units to the left so
then you wouldn't test that zero you'd
test that negative five does that make
sense